[Musica]
questa è una storia che parla di ombre e
di come uscire dalle ombre
dietro un grande uomo c'è
sì lo so so che avete la risposta dietro
a un grande uomo c'è una grande donna
lo sentiamo dire continuamente e farebbe
sembrerebbe un complimento no solo che
se la donna è dietro all'uomo vuol dire
che sta nell'ombra dell'uomo e questa è
la prima ombra che si palesa i nostri
occhi
nel mio lavoro di crescita personale e
professionale con le donne sono abituata
a porre loro molte domande
e oggi sono qui a proporvi alcune di
queste domande per riflettere insieme
chi sei tu siamo chi pensiamo di essere
e questo pensiero su chi siamo da dove
deriva
penso dunque sono
ma soprattutto come penso
cioè da chi quando come ho imparato a
pensare
sicuramente tra di voi donne e uomini
qui in sala
avete la risposta a queste domande ma
c'è una domanda molto più sottile e
molto meno scontata che ci permette di
fare riflessioni ancora più profonde
cosa non mi hanno detto che ha fatto sì
che il mio pensiero diventasse quello
che mi fa dire io sono
secondo me merita ripeterla e rileggerla
insieme cosa non mi hanno detto che ha
fatto sì che il mio pensiero
diventasse quello che mi fa dire io sono
ecco con queste domande implicitamente
aiuto le donne è in realtà anche molti
uomini
durante i miei seminari da oltre
vent'anni
vi assicuro che le risposte che le donne
trovano
o stupefacenti
improvvisamente
scoprono che non sono definite solo
dalla loro luce ma bensì dalle ombre
non le loro ombre come alcuni di voi
magari hanno immaginato ma le ombre
dell'inesplorato
dell'in esplorabile
quelle che vengono condizionate non solo
attraverso le parole ma attraverso i
comportamenti
attraverso
gli eccessi di protezione
e in questo momento vi parlo da donna a
voi uomini seduti qui in sala
uomini come contribuite a tenere le
vostre compagne le vostre figlie quelle
donne che così tanto amate nell'ombra
perché qui ci sono tutta una serie di
frasi ti proteggo io ci tengo io a te
penso io a te
in realtà invertendo una delle domande
che abbiamo appena visto improvvisamente
abbiamo un quadro molto più chiaro e
molto più ampio chi non sei tu e
soprattutto perché non lo sai
quali oscure recinzioni ti impediscono
di essere qualcuno o qualcosa d'altro da
ciò che sei
sembrano giochi di parole domande quasi
futili
speculazioni mentali che lasciano il
tempo che trovano ma vi assicuro che non
è niente di tutto questo
questo è un viaggio
e il viaggio della scoperta il viaggio
del risveglio
che accompagnerà molte donne e anche
alcuni uomini verso la libertà di essere
se stesse
seguitemi
quali sono queste zone oscure che ci
definiscono
sono quelle con cui ci lasciamo
consciamente definire
no
sarebbe troppo facile fosse così
sono così oscure così celate così
nascoste che non ci rendiamo neanche
conto che esistono
siamo così abituati a indossare una
maschera nella nostra quotidianità che
la chiamiamo persona
e questa maschera arriva a definirci
arriva arriva a definire chi siamo noi a
rappresentare la nostra identità
quello che non mostriamo quello che
resta sotto la maschera ma non viene mai
fuori crea una storia e una
rappresentazione di noi soffocata
al punto tale da andare a creare dei
condizionamenti della mente delle
persone
queste ombre possono essere incasellate
in questa forma
a questo punto vi chiedo chi non siamo
noi donne
o chi possiamo permetterci di essere
beh certamente io non sono una
e soprattutto non mi comporto come
poi faccio sempre la brava
so che la maggior parte di voi in questo
momento hanno completato le mie frasi
nella loro mente
perché nel nostro lavoro abbiamo
accettato il ruolo che abbiamo
se non lo fossimo già potremmo essere
delle leader
che cosa ci servirebbe per sviluppare la
nostra leadership
sicuramente il coraggio
la decisione il carisma la capacità di
comunicare in maniera efficace e
persuasiva
l'empatia
ma aspettate tutto questo lo abbiamo già
naturalmente dentro di noi
e allora perché non lo tiriamo fuori
nella coppia
quale ruolo assumiamo in automatico che
così
che cosa non diciamo che cosa accettiamo
che cosa subiamo che cosa non facciamo
all'interno della nostra coppia spesso
mi ritrovo ad aiutare le mie clienti in
ambiti che vanno ben oltre la crescita
sul lavoro
spesso gli ambiti personali e di coppia
entrano in gioco e mi ritrovo ad
esplorare il non detto in camera da
letto
sì perché il vero lavoro per liberarsi
dai vincoli della società ci richiede di
lavorare sul nostro essere a 360 gradi e
nella vita ho capito che come fai una
cosa fai tutte le cose
quindi dobbiamo lavorare sul nostro
ruolo di mamma di compagna diamante
di figlia di sorella di lavoratrice di
cittadina perché nell'ombra c'è tutto il
non detto
c'è tutto il non è il tuo posto non fa
per te
non è il tuo ruolo di donna
è sì ce lo dicono così spesso e ce lo
dicono così tanto che sembra quasi vero
ritorniamo alla domanda iniziale
all'affermazione iniziale dietro un
grande uomo
c'è una grande donna ce lo ripetono così
tante volte
da far sì che diventi la nostra realtà
da farci credere che sia reale
oggigiorno nessuno viene a dirci e tu
donna devi stare dietro un uomo
peccato che lo danno per scontato
spesso le mie clienti si dedicano per
anni a lavorare sullo sviluppo delle
loro capacità
vi assicuro che sono bravissime nel loro
lavoro rasentano quasi la perfezione
al punto tale che io la chiamo la
sindrome della brava ragazza
ma che poi molto spesso non fa carriera
perché tutte manca una cosa fondamentale
l'unica che permette loro di esprimere
quelle norme potenziale ma che è
confinato è limitato
messi in sordina da una sottile
soddisfazione dell'ego data dal circuito
sono tanto brava
io valgo valgo di più di tutti gli
uomini
qui senza di me non si potrebbe andare
avanti
come faccio io le cose non le fa nessuno
eh già
poi arrivano le grandi domande tipo
perché per le promozioni per la carriera
gli uomini mi passano davanti
questo è un ingiusto maschilismo
è sì
leggo ci dà quel sottile perverso
compiacimento che ci porta a crogiolarci
in pensieri inefficaci e a questo punto
la domanda sorge spontanea qual è la
cura che cosa posso fare io per uscire
dall'ombra che cosa posso fare io per
aiutare le mie sorelle le mie figlie le
mie amiche le mie colleghe a uscire
dall'ombra
iniziamo a smetterla di andare a
prendere competenze
lo sappiamo non sono abbastanza non
bastano mai
iniziamo a lavorare su un altro livello
logico iniziamo a lavorare sull'identità
sul io sono iniziamo a farlo anche in
altri ambiti della nostra vita della
coppia come amanti
in famiglia come madri come regine della
casa quel luogo sacro che nella nostra
cultura da sempre è stato celebrato come
il castello il palazzo dell'intimità
familiare qui dirò qualcosa che per
alcuni benpensanti potrebbe far storcere
un po il naso
il femminismo si è affermato negli
ultimi 50 anni e ha dimostrato il suo
limite intrinseco
nel portare avanti quella famosa idea di
parità di sessi che già esiste da sempre
dell'accettazione e nel rispetto dei
ruoli e delle peculiarità
perché se la donna era la regina che
l'uomo era il suo re
entrambi con amore e rispetto
sapevano andare avanti
oggi osservo la forte barriera
dell'egoismo di ciascuno dell'arroganza
della distanza creata dal falso mito di
essere uguali e pari se ci pensate qui
c'è un'ombra enorme il presupposto che
non lasciamo uguali e con le uguaglianza
ce la dobbiamo conquistare
con lotte e sacrifici
ricordiamoci che ciascuno di noi ha un
lato femminile e maschile e soltanto nel
momento in cui riconosciamo queste
nostre parti e riconosciamo le nostre
peculiarità e ci accettiamo possiamo
diventare un tutt'uno perché noi siamo
tutto e facciamo parte del tutto nella
società riportando in auge la magia
creativa di cui noi donne siamo
portatrici
e se fuori dall'ombra le donne fossimo
dotate di poteri magici i poteri di
guarigione
non solo per noi
per noi stesse per i nostri famigliari
ma per l'intera società in cui viviamo
vedete io credo che ogni donna ogni uomo
siano permeati di molte più capacità di
quanto mostrino dobbiamo soltanto
trovare la strada per uscire dalla
nostra ombra
per farci illuminare dalla lucentezza e
abbracciare le nostre ombre perché
soltanto nel momento in cui abbracciamo
le nostre ombre
iniziamo a risplendere nel mondo
oggi vi chiedo a partire da oggi chi
volete essere voi fuori dalle ombre
della realtà che vi è stata messa
davanti
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]